hey everyone happy wednesday and today
we're talking about new battlefield
portal details elden ring gameplay
that's on the way and more i'm persia
and this is your gamespot news
dice has given us an in-depth look at
battlefield 2042's portal mode today
which allows you to create custom games
with content from battlefield 3
battlefield bad company 2 battlefield
1942 and 2042. at launch you will be
able to hop right into default
experiences that will already be live so
you can replay classic maps in factions
you can also mix and match whichever
maps and factions for your own server
you can make your own simple edits to
existing experiences that will be
available by default but it was stated
in the blog post if you want to go all
out and start to create something truly
unique the rules editor will provide you
the deepest level of control over the
kind of battlefield experience that you
wish to create you'll be able to access
the battlefield portal from the web
whether it be your computer your phone
or tablet and you actually don't need to
own battlefield 2042 to access the
portal editor you just need an ea
account although you will need the game
to play on the settings that you create
the portal will allow you to see
experiences you've created and browse
experiences made by teams at ripple
effect and even use them as templates
you can customize settings from game
modes and maps to a wide variety of game
modifiers the modifiers can change
general gameplay like friendly fire
extreme weather events and aim assist to
soldier and vehicle adjustments you can
even edit the ui and ai and even whole
rule sets once you've curated every fine
detail of your personal battlefield
experience you can boot up a server and
play it and you can also send the code
to friends there will also be options to
kick or ban players who get out of hand
and those bands are set to carry over to
any new servers you decide to make we
got to see the battle of the bulge and
other iconic maps in action during the
portal trailer but let me know what your
perfect experience would be in the
comments below
bandai namco will show off more of from
software's eagerly awaited rpg eldin
ring on november 4th the publisher has
announced the company will release 15
minutes of presumably new footage of the
game bandai namco announced that it will
air at 7 a.m pacific and 10 a.m eastern
and you can watch the footage on youtube
and twitch eldon ring was originally
slated to launch in january of 2022
before it was pushed to february 25th a
month that is flooded with high profile
new releases you may not have to wait
until 2022 to play elden ring however as
there will be a closed network test
beginning november 12th and you can
register now for a chance to get in
those who are chosen for the beta test
can take part in five different sessions
held november 12th through 15th for
three hours each time
activision blizzard has delayed the
releases of both overwatch 2 and diablo
4 two of blizzard's most anticipated
upcoming titles as announced in its
latest quarterly earnings the company
said that both will launch later than
originally envisioned also stating our
teams have made great strides towards
completion in recent quarters but we
believe giving the team some extra time
to complete production and continue
growing their creative resources to
support the titles after launch will
ensure that these releases delight and
engage their communities for many years
into the future
the statement also noted that this will
also delay an anticipated financial
uplift for the company next year and
went on to say we are confident that
this is the right choice of action for
our people our players and the long-term
successes of our franchises no new
release dates were announced but given
that activision blizzard anticipates it
won't get a financial bump from them
next year they may not come until 2023
perhaps not until april 2023 due to the
beginning of the financial year in
another part of the investor
presentation activision blizzard noted
that the overwatch league will still
play an early build of overwatch 2
starting next spring following this
earnings release activision blizzard's
stock price started the day on wednesday
november 3rd down by more than 14 on the
new york stock exchange
in case you didn't know it's been animal
week on twitch and if you need a little
boost to get you to the weekend then
check out the newest category on the
platform called animals aquariums in
zoos you can use bits to feed ducks
swoon at the cute otters and vibe with
the jellyfish for a great cause thank
you all so much for watching and be sure
to like and subscribe so you don't miss
your next gamespot news update
[Music]
[Music]
you